-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy-nominated comedian
you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and in movies
such as "Ghostbusters"
and "Coming to America."
You can see her
in the new comedy series
"Our Flag Means Death,"
which is streaming on HBO Max,
with new episodes
every Thursday.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Leslie Jones, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hey!
-There she is.
[ Laughter ]
-What's up, baby?
-Leslie.
I have thought about you
so often this year.
You are one of the people
that I most associate
with the Los Angeles Rams.
You're such a giant fan
of the team
and I was so happy for you
when they won the Super Bowl.
Are you still on cloud nine?
-I'm a new fan.
Like it's easy to become a fan
when they win it,
you know what I'm saying?
So, when I got to L.A.,
I was like,
"Oh, Odell Beckham's on that?
Oh, Von Miller? Okay,
I'mma start cheering for them."
And, as soon as I started
cheering for them,
that's when
they started winning.
That's what I'mma tell myself.
-You know what?
This is very noble
because a lot of new fans
won't admit to everybody
that they came to it late
in the game,
but I think that's very,
very strong of you.
Very strong character to admit.
-You know I'm strong.
I'm strong, though.
I'm strong and a strong
character, so, yeah.
-But I hope people will
forgive me for thinking
You've been a lifelong Rams fan.
I just want to show one
of your many Instagram videos.
This is when the Rams were going
to the Super Bowl.
This does not strike me
as someone who's a new fan.
Let's take a look.
-[ Laughs ]
Aaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
Aaaaaaah!
I thought they was gonna
[bleep] choke!
[ Laughter ]
They didn't choke!
[Bleep] [Bleep] [Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Aaaaaaaaah!
We going to the Super Bowl,
bitch!
We going!
[ Laughter ]
-So, I mean, I think there are
a lot of people
who've been lifelong fans
who were like,
"Man, I don't care about them
as much as her."
[ Laughter ]
-Because, see, I knew the Rams
when Eric Dickerson was playing
with them, so.
-Sure.
That's the real deal.
Look, it all counts.
So, listen,
you had a cool thing happen,
which is not only was your team
in the Super Bowl
and not only did they win,
you also had a Super Bowl ad
with some other
famous Joneses --
Rashida Jones,
Tommy Lee Jones.
Was it a lifelong goal
to do a Super Bowl ad?
-Y'all love to put
lifelong things on.
-Were you on cloud nine, Leslie?
[ Laughter ]
-It's a Super Bowl
commercial, man!
I mean, yeah, it was fun.
It was very fun to do because,
you know, I love Tommy Lee,
even though we wasn't on set
at the same time.
People think we was like
really driving the trucks
and everything.
No, we was on the set on top
of these roller things
inside of the truck, acting like
we was driving the trucks.
Was I supposed to tell that,
Seth?
-I don't know.
I just like that I'm like,
"Was it a dream come true?"
And you're like, "No, and also,
we didn't even meet each other."
[ Laughter ]
-But, when he got on set --
-Again, I love --
The honesty, as always,
is just your main export.
They said that, when he got
on set, he was like --
[ As Tommy Lee Jones ]
I want to know two things --
what am I driving
and where's Leslie Jones?
[ Laughter ]
So that happened.
-That's pretty good.
I'm thinking right there,
we can step back and say
it was an accomplishment.
Hey, you also talk a lot,
and I think all of us enjoy,
every time there's an Olympics,
you sort of regale us
with your videos.
Winter Olympics --
are you a fan
of the Winter Olympics sports?
Is there any part of you
that wishes
you had taken them up
as a young person?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
No.
I mean,
I love the Winter Olympics
because I love the Olympics,
but none of that, none of that.
I don't wish to jump
off a mountain of snow.
I don't wish to go down a hill,
especially with that tree
out there murdering everybody.
[ Laughter ]
I don't wish to get
into a go-cart on sled,
like a sled cart.
[ Laughter ]
No, I don't wish
to do none of that.
[ Laughter ]
But I do wish to watch them.
Especially when they crash.
-What about the luge?
Is the luge what you mean,
or is that --
What about the luge?
-Luge, buge, cuge, all that.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not doing none of it.
It involves blades and a tunnel.
No, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-So that means hockey's out.
-Yes! Especially because you'll
get your fingers cut off
[ Laughter ]
and then the puck
just flying everywhere.
Do you see hockey players
never have no teeth?
[ Laughter ]
No. No. No, sir.
-You have beautiful teeth.
You wouldn't want
to lose your teeth.
-Man, I have beautiful teeth.
-I'm taking my kids skiing
right now.
I'm teaching them how to ski.
Would you ever want to come out?
-Of course you are.
Of course you are, white person.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's their birthright.
It's their birthright.
-Yeah.
I mean, like I wouldn't
even understand
a white person
that has never been skiing.
I wouldn't even understand it.
[ Laughter ]
Only time I've been on ski trips
is to do comedy
and I sit by the fire
in the ski boots.
I don't, no.
-You were an athlete
growing up, right?
You were a very talented
basketball player.
-Ah, I mean,
[ Laughter ]
I was good when I wanted to be.
I was very inconsistent.
-Okay.
-But when I wanted
to be good, I was good.
-What would you attribute
your inconsistency to?
-Just, you know,
not really loving basketball
as much as everybody
thought I could.
I was tall and I could make
a lay-up and, yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And so was there a moment --
When you first did comedy,
did the light go on and you
realized, "Oh, this is it"?
-Dude, as soon as I touched
the mic,
as soon as I touched the mic,
it felt like home.
I felt like I had been doing it
for years.
So I was like, "Oh!
I'm doing this
for the rest of my life.
Oh, this is so easy."
Like yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you certainly make it
look easy as well.
We're going to come back
and have a bunch of questions
about your new show.
We'll be right back
[ Cheering and applause ]
with more from Leslie Jones.